esta vez tenemos un problema realmente
interesante aquí tenemos una balanza en
la cual le hemos puesto tres masas estas
dos rojas que hemos denominado con x
tienen la misma masa esta tercera que le
hemos llamado y que tiene una masa
distinta es importante pensar que no
necesariamente son iguales xy pero ahora
veamos la situación lo que vemos en la
balanza es que la suma de las x ilife
están en equilibrio con estos 8
kilogramos que tenemos del otro lado
lo primero que te voy a preguntar es si
puedes escribir una relación matemática
que establezca esta relación que toda la
masa que está de este lado es
exactamente igual a la masa que está del
otro lado observemos nuestra situación
con más cuidado del lado izquierdo la
masa total son dos masas equis y un
alley osea lo puede escribir como 2x más
una y haber voy a escribirlo más hacia
el centro para que sea más claro tenemos
2 x + y esa es la masa total del lado
izquierdo 2 x más la masa total del lado
derecho es 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 o sea que
es igual a 8 observamos que la balanza
está en equilibrio o sea la masa total
del lado izquierdo es igual a la masa
total del lado derecho y podemos usar el
signo igual ahora quiero preguntarte
utilizando sólo la información que
tenemos aquí
y podemos hacer algo para resolver para
x oye hay algo que podamos hacer
parece que tenemos poca información o
sea si yo tomara de este lado y quitara
la y entonces para mantener el
equilibrio tendría que del otro lado
quitar algo equivalente allí pero como
no sé qué es de la misma manera
algebraica mentes y yo restará de ambos
lados entonces ahora del lado derecho
voy a seguir teniendo un menos y lo
mismo pasaría con la equis o sea como x
depende de iu y de x no puedo eliminar
con facilidad a cada una por suerte para
nosotros tenemos suficientes cubos x 7
entonces voy a tomar un cubo x y ponerlo
en la otra balanza y también voy a poner
un cubo y en la balanza y ahora voy a
poner tantos cubos uno necesite yo del
lado derecho hasta encontrar el punto de
equilibrio es obvio que si no pongo nada
del otro lado entonces la balanza no
estaría en equilibrio pero voy a poner
tantos cubos sean necesarios para llegar
al punto de equilibrio
y observo que llegamos al punto de
equilibrio cuando puse 5 cubos de un
kilogramo del lado izquierdo entonces
ahora te vuelvo a preguntar y podríamos
expresar de una manera matemática esto
que tenemos aquí que tenemos una x 1 y
un 5 de este lado
entonces tenemos una equis más una voy a
volver a escribirlo más hacia el centro
tenemos una equis más g
y aquí tenemos un 5 podemos observar que
la masa total de ambos lados es la misma
y entonces podemos otra vez usar el
signo igual y otra vez tomando esta
información aislada y pues no sé cuánto
vale ni x ni ye o sea no sé si es 1 o x
es 4 o al revés
pero algo interesante que podemos
observar es que ahora utilizando toda la
información de las dos balanzas que aquí
tenemos podremos saber el valor de x y
el de g y me gustaría darte unos
segundos para que pienses cómo podríamos
abordar esta situación
vamos a pensarlo de esta manera si ahora
yo sé que x es igual a 5 entonces de
este lado el cuántos cubos yo tendría o
mejor dicho cuánta masa yo tendría que
quitar de este lado a partir de lo que
ya conozco ya sabemos que x es igual a 5
kilogramos
entonces yo solo tendría que retirar 5
kilogramos de este lado y obviamente un
equis y 1 y de este lado y eso revelaría
el valor de x pero ahora mejor vamos a
pensarlo en términos algebraicos en
esencia al retirar de este lado de la
balanza una equis yo nadie yo estoy
restando a xy haber entonces voy a
escribirlo
un menos no mejor lo voy a escribir de
esta manera como menos una x más
y ahora que tengo que hacer del lado
derecho bueno si ya sabemos que x es
igual a 5 entonces tendré que retirar 5
kilogramos del lado derecho de la
balanza y todo esto lo puedo realizar
solo porque tengo la información que me
proporcionó la segunda balanza y
entonces lo que voy a hacer aquí es
restar 5 porque es lo que sabemos de
este lado vamos a restar 5
entonces si vamos a restar una equis y
una y de este lado déjame escribirlo de
esta manera
y vamos a distribuir el signo menos en
las dos
y entonces sería lo mismo que poner
menos x menos d
veamos qué pasará del lado izquierdo
entonces si yo tengo 2x y le quitó uno
pues nada más me queda una equis si yo
tengo un aire y quito una y entonces ya
no hay yes y visualmente lo podríamos
ver de este lado de la balanza sólo
tenemos una x ahora vamos del lado
derecho
entonces como quitamos x más de que vale
5 vamos a restar 5 porque eso ya lo
sabíamos entonces 8 menos 5 nos va a
quedar igual a 3 claro 8 menos 5 es
igual a 3 y entonces utilizando toda la
información que nos dieron estas dos
balanzas ahora podemos ver que x vale 3
ahora vamos con otra pregunta bueno ya
fuimos capaces de obtener el valor de la
masa de x podremos ser capaces de
determinar el valor de la masa de y
entonces podemos regresar otra vez a las
balanzas y en este caso esta será más
útil si sabemos que x es igual a 5 y
también sabemos ahora qué
x vale 3 entonces reemplazaremos a x por
3 y vamos a reescribir esto como tres
más y si tres más es igual a cinco
y ahora podríamos decir vamos a quitar
tres de ambos lados o sea si quito tres
del lado izquierdo tendré que quitar
tres del lado derecho y así lo tengo que
hacer para conservar el equilibrio y que
sería equivalente a restar tres de ambos
lados de mi ecuación
entonces de este lado sólo me queda allí
y del otro lado me queda 12 y entonces
obtuvimos que x es igual a 3 kilogramos
y que ya es igual a 2 kilogramos ahora
te toca verificar que utilizando estas
masas la masa total de ambos lados es la
misma y en este caso podemos que
comprobar que dos veces 3 es igual a 6
más 2
entonces la masa total del lado
izquierdo es 8 y está en equilibrio con
el otro lado que vale 8 y 3 + 2 es igual
a 5